MIGUEL MARQUEZ ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WHERE THE COMMUNITY IS
SCRAMBLING TO TRY TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR THESE MIGRANTS.
>> Reporter: THIS MAN WAS IN SAN
ANTONIO YESTERDAY ALONG WITH 50
OTHER VENEZUELAN MIGRANTS.
TODAY HE'S IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
WHEN YOU GOT OFF THE PLANE, I
ASK HIM, WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THIS PLACE?
BEAUTIFUL, GORGEOUS, THE PEOPLE
ARE VERY FRIENDLY.
HE SAYS IN TEXAS HE WAS PROMISED
HELP IF HE GOT ON THE PLANE, NO
IDEA WHERE HE WAS GOING.
THERE WERE THREE OPTIONS, HE
SAYS, WASHINGTON, UTAH, HERE IN
MASSACHUSETTS, WHATEVER WAS
AVAILABLE.
THE PLANE LEFT AND BROUGHT US
HERE.
IT'S A TACTIC WE'VE SEEN IN
TEXAS, ARIZONA AND NOW FLORIDA.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS SHIPPING
MIGRANTS TO SO-CALLED SANCTUARY
CITIES AND STATES WITH LITTLE TO
NO NOTICE.
>> THERE'S NO LOW THAT THOSE
PEOPLE WILL GO.
THEY'LL KEEP GOING LOWER AND
LOWER AND THEY'RE WILLING TO USE
HUMANS, CHILDREN, WOMEN,
FAMILIES AS POLITICAL PAWNS FOR
THEIR OWN GAME.
IT IS DEPRAVED.
IT IS EVIL.
IT IS WRONG.
BUT WHAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT IS
WHAT WE SEE HERE TODAY WHICH IS
AN ISLAND COMMUNITY AND A STATE
IN MASSACHUSETTS IS COMING
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THE PEOPLE
HERE.
>> Reporter: THIS 27-YEAR-OLD
MECHANIC SAYS HE'S BEEN WELCOME
WITH FOOD AND NEW CLOTHES HERE
ON THE ISLAND.
HE TELLS US HE MADE A DIFFICULT
MONTH AND A HALF LONG JOURNEY
FOR LIBERTY, DEMOCRACY AND THE
PROMISE OF AMERICA.
SO, HELLO, AMERICA.
>> Reporter: WHEN YOU STEP ON
AMERICAN SOIL YOU FEEL AT EASE
THAT YOU'RE HERE AND WELL
PROTECTED.
YOU LOSE THE STRESS OF THE
JOURNEY WE HAD TO GO THROUGH IN
SEVEN COUNTRIES.
VERY STRESSFUL ACROSS ALL OF
CENTRAL AMERICA.
THIS PARISH HOUSE BUSTLING WITH
ACTIVITY, VOLUNTEERS AND
ORGANIZERS WORKING SINCE
YESTERDAY TO PROVIDE FOOD,
SHELTER AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES.
>> WE'VE GOT THE BODIES TO DO
THIS.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WAS THE
SHORT NOTICE.
AND THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY
INTENTIONAL.
>> Reporter: JUST 20 MINUTES'
NOTICE SAYS THE AIRPORT MANAGER.
A DELIBERATE MOVE BY FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS WHO IS
TAKING CREDIT FOR THE SURPRISE
TRIP.
>> OUR MESSAGE TO THEM IS WE ARE
NOT A SANCTUARY STATE AND IT'S
BETTER TO BE ABLE TO GO TO A
SANCTUARY JURISDICTION AND WE
WILL HELP FACILITATE THAT
TRANSPORT FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO GREENER PASTURES.
>> Reporter: THAT MESSAGE NOT
SITTING WELL WITH OFFICIALS HERE
IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
>> WE'RE GOING TO COME TOGETHER
AND SUPPORT WHOEVER SHOWS UP
HERE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE FOOD, WATER
AND SHELTER THAT THEY NEED, YOU
KNOW, RON DeSANTIS AND
REPUBLICANS MIGHT WANT TO PLAY
POLITICAL GAMES WITH PEOPLE'S
LIVES, I BELIEVE THAT'S
INCREDIBLY INHUMANE TO BE USING
WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
AS A POLITICAL PAWN.
>> Reporter: NOW, WHAT'S TRULY
BIZARRE ABOUT THE SITUATION IS
THAT RON DeSANTIS -- AND HIS
DISLIKE OF THE GOVERNMENT THERE,
WHAT'S BIZARRE IS ALL OF THESE
IMMIGRANTS CAME FROM TEXAS AND
IT APPEARS ONLY THE PLANES WERE
PROVIDED BY FLORIDA SPECIFICALLY
TO BRING THEM HERE AND AS YOU
MENTIONED, WITHIN HOURS, THOSE
BUSES AT THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
RESIDENCE IN D.C., BUT, LOOK,
WHATEVER HAPPENS HERE IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, THEY CAN
HANDLE THE 50 HERE.
THEY ARE GETTING ON IT AND
BELIEVE IF THERE ARE MORE PLANES
THAT COME THEY'LL BE READY FOR
THEM, JAKE.
>> THANKS SO MUCH.
AT FIRST OFFICIALS ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WAS UNSURE WHO SENT
THEM BUT GOVERNOR DeSANTIS TOOK
CREDIT SAYING STATES LIKE
MASSACHUSETTS, NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA WILL BETTER
FACILITATE THESE INDIVIDUALS
THROUGH THEIR DESIGNATION AS
SANCTUARY STATES AND SUPPORT FOR
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S OPEN
BORDER POLICIES.
LET'S BRING IN STEVE.
STEVE, GOVERNOR DeSANTIS HAS BIG
POLITICAL AMBITIONS.
EVERY MOVE HE MAKES SEEMS TO BE
CAREFULLY CALCULATED AND THOUGHT
OUT.
WHAT DOES HE GAIN FROM THIS.
>> Reporter: THIS WASN'T
SOMETHING HE HATCHED OVERNIGHT
BUT HAS BEEN QUITE PUBLICLY
PLOTTING THIS IN THE PUBLIC EYE
FOR MONTHS NOW.
HE HAS THREATENED TO SHIP
MIGRANTS TO ANYWHERE THAT MIGHT
GIVE DEMOCRATS HARBOR AND
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND EVEN SAID
THE PRESIDENT'S HOME STATE OF
DELAWARE.
SO POLICYWISE THIS IS SOMETHING
HE HAS SAID FOR AWHILE.
POLITICALLY THIS CHECKS A LOT OF
BOXES FOR HIM.
IT GETS HIS BASE REALLY EXCITED.
IT'S AN ISSUE THEY CARE ABOUT.
IT CAUSES A LOT OF ANGUISH AND
OUTRAGE AMONG DEMOCRATS WHICH
SCORES A LOT OF POINTS IN
TODAY'S REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT GETS MEDIA
COVERAGE.
THAT IS A FORMULA HE HAS USED
TIME AND TIME AGAIN TO GET AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THESE ISSUES
THAT ARE MOST ANIMATING GOP
VOTERS.
>> SO SOME GOP VOTERS IN FLORIDA
ARE VENEZUELAN AMERICANS.
THAT'S KIND OF LIKE A GROWING
FORCE IN FLORIDA POLITICS AS I
DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU.
A LOT OF THESE MIGRANTS ARE
VENEZUELANS.
MIGHT THERE BE ANY RISK OF ANY
BACKFIRE ON GOVERNOR DeSANTIS?
>> JAKE, IT'S A GREAT QUESTION
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR HAS BEEN A
HARD LIFE LINER ON IMMIGRANT
ISSUES SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE AND
HASN'T HURT HIM TOO MUCH WITH
THE LATINO AND HISPANIC
POPULATIONS THAT MAKE UP SUCH A
LARGE PART OF THE VOTING BASE
THERE.
BUT ONE STEP BACK A SECOND.
THE VENEZUELAN POPULATION IS
HUGE IN FLORIDA.
IT'S -- HALF OF THE
VENEZUELANING THAT LIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES ACTUALLY LIVE IN
FLORIDA.
IN FACT, 100,000 LIVE IN THE
MIAMI AREA ALONE.
AND MANY OF THEM VOTE, IN FACT,
MANY OF THEM VOTE REPUBLICANS.
A LOT OF THEM WERE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS IN 2020.
YOU KNOW, THEY ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THAT HE WAS DOING A GOOD JOB OF
STANDING UP TO MADURO, THE
DICTATOR WHO RUNS VENEZUELA, SO
IF THEIR POLITICAL CALCULUS
CHANGES, YOU KNOW, YOU AND I
BOTH KNOW A LOT OF RACES ARE WON
AND LOST ON THE MARGINS AND
ALREADY SEEING VENEZUELAN
LEADERS DOWN IN FLORIDA.
THEY ARE HOLDING PRESS
CONFERENCES TODAY WHERE THEY
WERE EXPRESSING OUTRAGE AT THIS
DECISION.
IF THIS MOVES THE DIAL AT ALL,
IT COULD BE TROUBLE FOR HIM.
>> THESE ARE -- I'M ASSUMING --
VICTIMS OF MADURO, VICTIMS OF
HIM.
STEVE CONTORNO.
>>> GOVERNOR ABBOTT SENT THESE
WITH NO HEADS-UP TO OFFICIALS IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, NO HEADS-UP
TO PROVIDE CARE FOR THEM.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO THIS?
IS THIS A GOOD WAY TO PROTEST
THE COUNTRY'S FAILING
IMMIGRATION POLICYS?
>> CLEARLY, CLEARLY, TRAGIC AND
JUST A MANIFESTATION OF DeSANTIS
PLAYING MONKEY SEE, MONKEY DO
WITH OUR GOVERNOR AND HAVE A
HANDFUL OF RIGHT WING NUT JOB
GOVERNORS THAT HAVE BEEN MAN
TESTING THEMSELVES IN THIS WAY
AND FEEDING MORE RED MEAT TO
THEIR BASE AND ALIENATING THE
MIDDLE OF ROAD REPUBLICANS BUT
IN TEXAS WHERE WE ALREADY HAVE A
MASSIVE LABOR SHORTAGE WE'RE
USING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
EXPORT PEOPLE AND AS IN THIS
CASE AS YOU MENTIONED THESE ARE
VENEZUELANS WHO ARE BROKEN.
WHO ARE COMING FROM A COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP MUCH LIKE THE
VENEZUELANS AND CUBANS IN
SOUTHERN FLORIDA WATCHING THIS
AND PROBABLY IN DISGUST
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY MAY FEEL
WITH WHAT PARTY THEY FOLLOW THEY
ARE COMING FROM A COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP AND MADE IT TO OUR
COUNTRY AND NORMALLY WE TAKE
CARE OF THESE PEOPLE, WE ARE
GOOD AMERICANS THAT PROMOTE
DEMOCRACY AROUND THE WORLD AND
WE'RE SHUTTING THE DOOR ON
OTHERS THAT ARE SUFFERING IN
DICTATORSHIPS IN VENEZUELA AND
CUBA WHEN WE'RE SENDING THIS
MESSAGE TO THE WORLD.
IT'S SHAMEFUL.
>> GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AND
GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAY THEY FEEL
COMPELLED TO DO IT AND CALL ON
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
CONGRESS TO TAKE ACTION, TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IRRESPONSIBILITY
OF SANCTUARY CITIES AND
SANCTUARY STATES.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIPS -- THESE ARE
VENEZUELANS WOULD CAME FROM A
MADURO DICTATORSHIP.
I THINKS THAT SO SOMETHING --
THEY'RE HAVE TROUBLE EXPLAINING
TO CUBANS AND NICARAGUANS AND
VENEZUELANS IN SOUTHERN FLORIDA
WHO FLED THE SAME DICTATORSHIP
MAYBE IN DIFFERENT CONDITIONS
BUT IN THEIR HEART THEY KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS WRONG AND
THAT'S NOT WHO AMERICA IS AND
NEVER HAVE BEEN.
THIS IS A NEW RADICAL RIGHT WING
WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT
IS SHOWING THIS NEW FACE TO OUR
COUNTRY AND TO THE WORLD AND
IT'S REALLY SHAMEFUL.
>> CONGRESS HASN'T PASSED
SWEEPING IMMIGRATION REFORM
SINCE REAGAN WAS PRESIDENT.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE THEORETICALLY
THERE SHOULD BE A COMPROMISE
THAT INCLUDES HUMANITY AND
BORDER SECURITY.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE SEE PASSED?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I JUST FILED A BILL CALLED THE
SAFE ZONE AGO AND WHAT THE SAFE
ZONE ACT DOES, IT CREATES A
PLACE ON THE BORDER OF GUATEMALA
AND MEXICO FOR ASYLUM SEEKERS TO
SHOW UP THERE INSTEAD OF HAVING
TO MAKE IT TO OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AND TAKE THE PRESSURE OFF
OUR BORDER AND REMOVE THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT OR THE CARTEL
ELEMENT FROM HIJACKING THESE
MIGRANTS.
THEY PAY 5,000 TO 8,000 TO GET
TO MY SOUTHERN BORDER AND WE
CALCULATED THEY MADE $5 BILLION
LAST YEAR.
THIS IS THE ONLY TRUE
COMPREHENSIVE BORDER PLAN THAT
WOULD BRING LONG-TERM SOLUTIONS
AND HOPE TO GET BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THIS IS NOT A SHOW BUSINESS TYPE
OF BIG.
THIS IS SOMETHING I TOOK THE
FIRST AND ONLY BIPARTISAN GROUP
OF MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO OUR
BORDER TO SEE WHAT WAS HAPPENING
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
DEMS USED TO POINT THE FINGER AT
CHILDREN IN CAGES NOW
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING DOWN EVERY
WEEK FOR POLITICAL PLOYS TO TAKE
PHOTOS OF MIGRANTS THAT ARE
CROSSING THE BORDER AND BLAMING
BIDEN.
WE NEED A COMPREHENSIVE IDEA OF
WHAT COULD BE BRING SOLUTIONS
AND CLEARLY WE NEED AN
IMMIGRATION PLAN THAT WORKS BUT
THE ASYLUM SYSTEM ISN'T
FUNCTIONING AT ITS BEST AND I
THINK WE CAN MAKE IT SAFER, MORE
HUMANE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE